PEGI 16 knee-highs back the kingdom of  Arusha declared war on the oathean  Federation but isn't that country a  whole continent away from here yet what  is a nation  suit was ineffective  it's still what the laund of flying was  full potential  my grandfather tossed a magazine to meet  the read soon there will be no one  gripping a control stick and taking to  the skies here comes the UAV quit  [ __ ] around and get the hell out of  there amidst the swirling clouds Fighter  Squadron was trying to help its allies  rich safety it's right Mikey  it really is foolish isn't it yep it  sure is  the enemies in the cloud damn it  the Arsenal bird  I decide when  sure I'm probably heading straight into  hell  no one here what are you leading on  smaller  if you damn cool  [Music]  you